let's hold our horses the interim
champion thanks to [ __ ] chin making
pro moves gonna be the guest of the year
will it be Krista Lea Michael Rapaport
will / coming in hot man come in hot it
to the funniest guys in the world who
answered the bell brian counts out
shooting a movie in China say the city
told me a low-budget movie and barely
it's important scene because he's there
for a day and flying back oh yeah with
you doing throwing coins into a airplane
engine over there oh legalish yeah like
chins ancestors you're not happy with -
I got to introduce you guys this Tony
Hinchcliffe yeah and Jeremiah Watson
yeah watch hands by that good two hours
of show before this yeah what's going on
dudes the champ is here the real champ
is here the co-host of the year is here
your interim champ isn't here the
interim champ that chin created with his
promo videos Oh who's gonna be the guest
of the year will it be Michael Rapaport
Will Sasso Chris D'Elia
up vo Vaughn who will it be no Tony no
Tony in the video you guys can cure any
chance you guys Bernie Sanders me know
we did if you're not in the if you're
not in the debate you don't have a
chance you CNN me I got chin negative
news biz you have some sort of issue
with him - yeah that's cuz his grandma
through the coins in the airplane inch
and you brought it to life and I did the
impression and he was insulted and he
thinks those guys are famous and now you
have that guy as your champion the bat
king or whatever you guys call them yeah
what he's called you guys like silly
words huh silly country words he's the
only guy who's country accent gets
thicker the longer he lives in LA that
guy really figured it out huh it's like
if you
like if you left a blue-collar comedy
DVD next to a nuclear power plant next
to a thesaurus
oh man you ever see hippopotamus balls
fall off and wear sunglasses no nobody
has ever seen that because it doesn't
happen champ this is the ninth time ever
this morning thank you really
here's another one coming up the ranks
it's the third thing man the belt though
then you got your guy get your right
hand man okay I have a right hand man no
I know he doesn't have a right hand man
I have a real manager here a guy to
carry my belt for me you know and I mean
with the Paul bear like [ __ ]
Undertaker yeah we just said way more
handsome Oh Jerome I don't but I'm
excited to be back to reclaim my
position hopefully chin is in - oh my
god weirdo eater Michael Rapaport
yes bubbly we remember him how'd you get
Bobby Lee in there huh how are you able
to squeeze him and you guys have the
same face that's why I know what's going
on here not the first idea so he's gonna
take that belt make earrings out of it
just give me that [ __ ] belt I'm gonna
melt that thing you make a bracelet
herself
oh man that makes sense he would write
all this I told you ma'am before we got
in there I might have to create an
interim belt because I'm pulling a Dana
White yeah because the over here trying
to act big-time
I'm the red book in my few times I like
dude a busy man excuse me sir dude I'll
do I owe you can't defend your belt yeah
I'm ready commenting yeah ready to go
taking it to the White House
that's what I'm gonna do when I win
co-hosted the year I'm gonna call Trump
and I'm gonna get me in for this photo I
got that I got the new championship
fighter and the kid and co-host belt let
me and give me access a boy as long as
you say you're a fake it's not like
there's people vying to get in there
they might let you in yeah it's true
that the belt will give me access I'll
show them some of my racist clips of me
doing impressions of Asian women and
he'll like me right
[ __ ] your name though bucket you guys
coming off tour you guys are all over
man so how does it work because you have
kill Tony and then you is it you and
Jeremiah you guys both go on the road
then you bring like tell me how it works
then you bring red banners that work
yeah we have before he says for those
you don't know and you live under a rock
or your nicest Tony does a show kill
Tony yeah which is every Monday night at
the Comedy Store I've been on Bryan's
been on it everyone's been on everyone's
it's killing it you guys bring in like
potluck right and they have comics with
your name in the Hat
yeah I may come up they have one minute
to do stand-up then you have a panel of
judges
yeah man Jeremiah is in the band behind
and there's a theme every week yeah he
plays luck in hilarious plays a
different character every week you never
know who he's gonna be in Fort Wayne
they were they were angels angels they
were basketball players in Cleveland and
they were Joe Rogan yeah I'm just
buffers on you Joe Rogan that was
hilarious Oh Saturday night ish oh yeah
if you like Joe market you could make
certain that life no no no yeah working
towards it oh yeah yeah that's the goal
yeah I mean I love that show
but I'm super grateful what I get to do
on kill Tony every week because we have
a ton of creative control because we get
it like I like Tony basically lets us do
kind of whatever we want like we never
tell Tony and Brian what characters for
I love that so they're always genuinely
surprised
just like the audiences and then he's
just like oh okay let's don't deal with
this now then who you come up with the
idea every week me Joel Jimenez and
first down yeah oh you guys really yeah
Joel Berg on the drums he's and how they
work so you who comes up with the themes
you guys just talk and then we just talk
we start sending text messages and we
have like a giant list of like potential
character ideas that will sit down like
every once in a while would be like
maybe we could do this or that and then
sometimes it'll depend on like what's
topical or like you know when Gio was
coming on the five year anniversary we
knew that he and Dom are gonna be the
guess a couple months outs were like we
got to make this special and Joel played
he did his impression of Tony
Pat Reagan did his impression of Brian
Redman and
Chris Dylan did his impression of Josh
Martin the producer of Felucia and Epix
so I started the show that night did you
get the idea for the show well you know
I was hosting at the Comedy Store pretty
regularly like the potluck part where
comedians do three minutes like the way
into the comic see like comes in the
emcee like every this is a while ago a
lot yes exactly
people having a year Tony whenever you
he's the host because you'd be pretty
harsh on me yeah I'd make fun everybody
I'm a roaster it was all in my skill set
and I didn't have a full-blown outlet
for it so it was just a you know yeah
just whacking people's souls and if they
survived they got stronger and if they
didn't then they weren't gonna do
anything anyway so then what did the so
then from doing that so often I'm like
and I was late to the podcast party I
thought I was late now we're saying
we've already celebrated five years and
but like everybody had a podcast and you
know I was in Rogen's circle and we're
in doing you know a lot of shows with
red band and the whole crew and
everybody and everybody was wondering
when I was gonna start my podcast but I
wanted to do something a little bit
different than you know then in the
studio thing so I decided to do it live
and the Comedy Store was awesome and
they were open-minded to the idea and
they let they let us run with it and
it's a big commitment for them for like
hey every Monday yeah I'm gonna take
over the main room yeah well it started
in the belly room it started the first
night we only have like eight people in
the room and six of them signed up and
two of them were there could for another
show that they thought was gonna be
there but yeah and they but they come
every week ever since then Laney and
Jerry and you know it'd be they bumped
us down to the main room and now we're
packing that baby up every week it's
crazy it's just chaos doesn't matter who
the guests are doesn't matter if we
announce them you know people come from
around the world and when we do these
shows on the road now which is so
exciting it's just the craziest most
awesome excited fans because they know
anything can happen whereas Saturday
Night Live appears to be an improvised
show or so like a [ __ ] rehearsal
well written it's written by 30
different people those writers in the
world
yeah well they have a week though
most available writers pretty good
though it's a monster you came off there
yeah back in the day yeah yeah by the
time Jeremiah gets on it kill Toni's
gonna have more people watching it than
realize you're not gonna like it there
bro her doesn't really mean two new guys
yeah well it is interesting because
those people have almost zero creative
can I don't think people know like that
I'm sorry live yeah then you can pitch
ideas don't like to have the pitch yeah
but it's tough to get yeah good luck
getting that through the head writer
that ones to keep his job yeah he wrote
the whole thing oh yeah well what are
you doing your [ __ ] do we need to yeah
exactly so you know there's so much
politics and crazy stuff going I've seen
it on the Comedy Central shows that I've
written on and worked on and everything
I mean and I've read the SNL books and
now it's 2018 who knows how out of
control it is I don't know I haven't
watched it in years yeah I record them
watch my like Wednesday so I'm a loser
no oh yeah but so the kill Tony on the
road is it almost better on the road
because I feel like bring get some
variables you're not gonna get in LA yes
I get even for me when I go on the road
I stop bringing an open with me because
I wanted the curveball meeting new
comics in every city and it's a
curveball out oh you hate some people
are like Jesus Christ right and I was
terrible alright or they're amazing yeah
heard of them or I like the curveball or
there's a little combination of both
where they kill but with local
references that you have no idea whether
it reminds me of crossing Benson Avenue
it's at Dairy Queen the crowd so when
you go on the road though it's a
different animal oh yeah the crowds just
so into it they know how anything can
happen so you know like to start two
days ago to show and the first thing we
pulled out of the bucket was this
awesome
you know autistic he had a fanny pack
the thick bottle coke bottle glasses or
whatever they call it say no more family
I mean it's like the Rain Man of comedy
exactly exactly and
you know it was his first time onstage
and he did pretty good and you know had
a great interview portion funny guy
naturally funny getting this shot and
you know people realize that they're
watching his first time on stage live
right now and you can't make that up and
you can't pretend like we know they know
what we're gonna ask or what his answers
are so the magic that happens is
something you can't find anywhere that
because everything's so overproduced I
was always surprised when I started
working on TV shows how produced they
were like I was like oh right that's
that that segment there'll be funny on
its own we don't even have to worry
about it and they're like what do you
mean every single thing has to be
written now so much jobs on I used to
work in morning radio and you'd be
really surprised how much everything is
orchestrated morning radio even the call
ins are most of them are fake like most
of the call ins of people who are
calling in like for segments and
different stuff like that Wow our paid
actors which is like do my mom like you
have no friends who would do it for ya
right somebody yeah it's yeah so like
any of those like you know Ryan Seacrest
like War of the Roses and all that so
it's all fake guys there anything worse
the morning radio now hug it out still
around AKO time zone zone 5 here here we
go we got Brent job in the building
there's nothing worse for me when I have
to do press hey we got Brent job in the
bill knees here so incoming gig Conor
McGregor could begin and I'm like yeah
it's gonna selling so watch your bunch
the face up what is that for you
my favorite thing is there's always a
part where they acknowledge that you
have a podcast but they don't really
want to talk about it and they don't
want to face the fact that like you know
you have a following from Mod cast about
they're sitting there like see I get a
different thing I get it I get them
story and jump on this call wind it
we're gonna do this about 15 minutes and
I just started to podcast you mind
jumping on with me we'll just do a quick
hour I'm not doing your podcast I break
out my [ __ ] podcast falling on you no
I'm not doing your podcast yeah
yeah my favorite is like when you're
explaining to them like yeah we do it
every Monday it packs up the main room
of the Comedy Store it's a live show and
you just get to see these sad morning
radio DJs go further and further into
their shell I go yeah they're like well
we'll be right back I got lucky because
I used to used to be my dream when I was
a little kid to be a radio DJ I thought
it was the coolest possible gig I mean I
was like a little kid like an 11 very
high I was a little kid and I'm like
that's the coolest gig I was recording
songs off the radio on one cassette
player and then you'd switch the other
cassette you know what I mean and I
would host my own radio show and I was
obsessed with this one DJ back in
Youngstown I won't say his name so it's
not that's no fair but I was awesome I
was writing to my shadow he was on hot
101 he was and I was a big afternoon DJ
on a pop station but I thought it was
the coolest thing at the time and then
one day they announced like hey go down
to phantom fireworks tomorrow and you'll
get to you'll get to meet uh ba ba ba ba
you know this DJ and I went and I met
him and it was one of the most
disappointing sad things just said of
boos all by himself just no one no one
weird no everybody was just walking
right by him to go into the fireworks
store and I went up and I was like hey
man you're one of my heroes nice to meet
you and he's like okay good yeah sure
yeah DJ's tough gig man they're up there
like four sometimes 3:30
yeah so do I every morning yeah if you
look at just the stats of people that
work those shifts they don't live as
long as others it's a rough gig man yeah
the morning you you looked up a study
recently that shows study this study was
just conducted the census showed the
DJ's die earlier than normal people back
to yo the studio production oh I know
the Australia for a career change oh
never mind never mind
can't do it where did the idea come up
to have the live band like we're I what
I'm trying to get to is where did you
and Jeremiah connect oh man I mean
Jeremiah was one of the guys that I
would always make sure that I put up
back when I was regular hosting the
Comedy Store you know way back in the
day when I only had two or three four
spots to give out period how many years
goes this this is um seven eight years
ago seven eight nine ten years ago right
in that pocket and you know I just
always liked his style he was always
doing different stuff taking chances
instead of so many people that were just
trying to hope that the talent
coordinator saw them crush for three
minutes and thing they did the same
three minutes every week and I was like
I'm not doing that
yeah and so you know I always knew that
I could count on him to at least do
something different and we just kept our
our rapport going even though we're
completely different sides of the
spectrum he's completely you know silly
he does characters he's spectrums on
this it's literally on the spectrum and
so yeah so the evolution happened on Cal
Tony we used to have a head of security
called the iron patriot and he got a
little too big for his britches and said
that he was leaving the show and all
this this is right before it blew up
like the week before it blown out they
found him they found him on Hollywood
Boulevard though correct yes yeah that's
a fun fact about that guy what yeah well
well he came to us at the end of episode
one of kill Tony which even then it
wasn't even called kill Tony was called
Hinch CliffsNotes for one or two
episodes and then tough yeah yeah how do
you spell that right yeah so at the end
of the episode he came up to me in a
Iron Man type of suit and said hey I
want to be part of the show if it's at
all possible like he's in a full suit
with a robot voice and everything I'm
like great you're the new head of
security
you're just gonna stand next to the
stage after a few weeks we realized that
every once in a while he would say
something really funny through his robot
voice and we thought it was funny so we
put a mic on him
and then then he got his ego just
exploded this man in a robot suit
literally is like in demand he literally
was he's like if you guys don't move to
a bigger podcast network I'm going to
leave the show permanently oh [ __ ]
now he's just off his gourd he just
messages us in the DM he's like I will
pay you $5,000 to be back on the show
gonna [ __ ] come shoot up the store
probably one or two yeah what it's
probably gonna happen that's probably
gonna be what kills Tony replacement
iron Patriot's like Tiffany Haddish was
an iron Paige go for Willy hunter
Jeremiah was an iron patient so many
great minds and then eventually I found
Pat Reagan who's a great musician and
they have a band together now but when I
found Pat again it was a guy who I
noticed right before roast battle and
stuff was doing different songs every
week doing different things and we're
taking real chances even though his
reputation was on the line
you know we saw him kill last week and
that's when most people start to phone
it in like well I gotta do the stuff
that's gonna kill but nope he just kept
trying different stuff and I thought it
was so cool and I told him that I
thought he was amazing he gave me a CD
of his music which 99 times out of a
hundred I don't listen to and the one
time out of a hundred that I did I'm
like this is garbage and throw it out
the window
but I listened to his album and my mind
was blown Pat Reagan smells like Shi tea
it's called and and I just fell in love
with the guy's artistic capabilities I
think to the common theme here you keep
talking I don't think people realize
when you say when you saw Jeremiah when
it's all Reagan when you see these guys
a lot of guys with Tommy store is you
can't go do the same set every whatever
Tuesday or Wednesday and you know it's
getting it last cuz you're being on the
road or wherever yeah it's going on the
road but it takes a [ __ ] brave soul
to get out there and go you know what I
haven't tried this before just thought
of it I'm gonna hit the stage even
though people know me and I'm gonna go
out and see how it goes it's like when
you see our
Resler hit a standing knock out or a
stand-up guy hit a jujitsu move in a
fight you're like whoa you learn that
he's gone out of his comfort zone to
shock his opponent that thought the
other thing was coming I think that's
where is that is that where you got
because jamya does a show called stand
up on the spot once a month yeah it's my
favorite show at The Comedy Store
because it literally forces you and I'm
a I'm a control freak I'm a guy who I go
through my cell my got down to the word
it's this yeah down to the word but I'm
gonna leave some open to have fun with
it I'm a control freak and yours you've
been like for awhile like do you I do
stay on the spot and rogues like you
gotta do them like I'll get to it and it
was the same thing in I told you this at
the store it's like in sparring I knew I
should spar with that guy because I was
so scared of him how to avoid him
because it's my toughest matchup or
whatever you get one up on me
so I always avoided him but I knew to
get better I had to go [ __ ] spar that
guy yep Jeremias show stamp on spot was
that guy in the comedy circle I knew I
had to do it but I knew I have no
control of it I've not there's no
variables I have no idea how it's gonna
go so I was always avoiding it so I told
him I think my hey the next one put me
in no matter what [ __ ] happens I'm
showing up yeah it's the best show it's
like forced you're literally forced to
come with me after yeah you have to come
up with it all off the top of your head
in the moment people are yelling out
suggestions and then you have to take
those suggestions and then great stain
upon the spot and just like that tough
guy that you don't want to spar you
can't beat them if you don't spar with
them and you're never happier if you get
around in on him right so if you do a
show like that and do good you feel like
a beast you have new material you
artistically are challenge you know
challenged and gratified like there's
nothing better to me nothing makes me
happier we talk about this all the time
then a new bit working nothing better
yeah the best money in the bank its
money like this investment it's having a
baby
look it's like your baby is healthy yes
gonna be a real baby it's gonna be a
huge it's gonna take on life and you can
find all that at the stand up on the
spot and quell Tony's same thing any
improvised show I did a show with a girl
who was on there when when I was on
there with Brian there was a girl who
was on there kind of cheated well I was
like damn she's weird as [ __ ] you might
slit her wrists after this but she was
cool yeah I forget who she was
but then I did a show at the Ice House
this like two weeks ago and is one of
red band shows and I fly down there and
it's like 115 degrees outside and
there's literally seven people in all of
AI cells I go up to the manager go did
you guys eat like a Bob's dead something
gonna bomb scare so I'm like a miser no
one and she was like it's hot as [ __ ]
out knowing ya like I've never seen this
like this yeah so yeah I don't know
something all right
I check in I'm literally seven people in
the crowd but she goes on before me and
just destroyed it and then she's like
remember me I'm like God I don't I'm a
dick she's like I was on to kill Tony
when you were coach or when you were a
guy up yes really and she I was like
[ __ ] that's right she was hilarious I
love it it's the most fun thing getting
to see what happens with some of these
people even if they bomb their first
time are their first five times on it's
it's it's a huge accomplishment that
sixth time on they kill it at that point
I was doing her I was doing something
mad I don't I say the baby because I
don't want this guy's name you know I
was doing something at a venue and
Showtime was there to see me do my set
and the show was start at 9:00 9:45 and
it's 10:45 I'm like I'm the only comic
in the back of like what the [ __ ] and
the lady run the joint goes oh there's
no one here we need to go out there MC
and just do an hour what she was just
did you I do - as long as you can cuz we
don't know where anyone else is I want
come on man I went that's show time down
there come on help me out here she goes
I don't what to do and she'll be telling
you this
are there any other comics and this guy
goes I'm a comic out who's what's your
name and again I'm gonna say his name
and I go cooing he goes dude I know
you're a comic killing me doing comics I
did kill Tony oh now I'm like you just
did the one mini us yeah and then he's
like but I've done more coming anyone
else there she goes so you'll go out
oh oh now you should have just gone out
and I should have you'll be sad there'd
be an easy gig he say the comedy and
then goes out there and ate all the
dicks that was possible but he found
man-eating pigs around like a hot dog
Brendan jobs favorite comic he chose me
for this gig saw me on kill Tony you
know I could eat dicks for 60 seconds
but watch me for 10 minutes even
Showtime changed the channel time was
like now he's dying up there guys did
you oh you wrote for do you help out
with any of that stuff Gemma with the
the roast battles or anything oh you
know I write on the Comedy Central Roast
with all the celebrities but I'm pretty
sure I'm done with that I think I'm
retiring because I am taking a stand
that I should be on the dais for these
roasts from now on % I should be on them
however I did your managers say about it
or agent same thing they think I'm right
there let's go me central say be what's
the other like what the [ __ ]
you know Comedy Central is uh you know
it's one of those things to where they
don't really show they're uh they
they're not very clear about what or why
or anything you know it's one of those
things to where well that's why I cried
when they tell me Central's and I'm and
also you know they let they let the they
let the guest of honor at those big
roasts decide who's on there's like most
recent ones Willis exactly Bruce Willis
is really good friends with da my rare
and Kevin Pollak so I was sort of you
know and by the way I loved ah my rarest
I loved like so nice to know my god like
a bath and rest a father
he's so cool he's in everything one of
those guys only one who doesn't like him
if you don't I will suck it yes
absolutely and if you don't like them I
will push
you into Brendan so he will sock you in
the bedroom I play a lot of sex moaning
yeah yeah it's right in the ear so like
when I saw Tom was on it I'm like you
know what this is awesome this is a cool
last roast for me to ride on and help
everybody out got to work with Martha
Stewart again got to try to work with
Dennis Rodman turns out not the greatest
reader sort of hard to be a great writer
when the person anyway yeah you know
Joyce read good one of those things but
he saved us from nuclear war so I can't
complain roast though so how do those
wrote when those roasts how does it work
like you they give you the the subject
Bruce Willis the new addict all these
[ __ ] roasts yeah and then you know
when people are booked to be on the dais
you get a chance to write from their
perspective so it's like Martha
Stewart's in and I'm like here we go
let's do it again so me and the guy Mike
Ferrucci genius this is one of these
Wizards that we have no idea stand up to
he used to but then he started just
making you know what I mean like he's
one of those guys that you know they
tell you everybody's getting paid the
same amount in these writers rooms you
know favored nations or whatever and he
this is one of those guys looks like a
gun for hire a freak he's a monster
monster and when him and I get in a room
together it is uh it we just come out
with you we come out walking like Connor
does in the Octagon but with pieces of
paper like wait till you see what we
wrote this you know what oh this shows
does he work done because it's not that
frequent he is so great at what he does
that he does like these you know he's
one of those guys that can do like these
gigantic corporate gigs you know that
pay really well like if a cowboy wants
to roast is other cowboy friends the oil
tycoons in Texas guess what they end up
finding out about this guy like it's one
of those things and but him and I wrote
the original Martha script from the
Bieber roast which sort of went on to be
considered I think one of the greatest
roast performances
of all time and got us both a lot of
work and then does Jeff Ross also write
or no Jeff Rossen or himself
yeah yeah he was because I saw him at
the I did a set and then he was up in
the alar and I went to watch him he was
just he had his notes and was going over
all the Bruce Willis stuff you know he's
the man he's so great at it you know he
was basically like you know built at the
Friars Club in New York City you know
what I mean like he's an OG really is
the roastmaster general and he really is
undeniably awesome at all that so you
know he goes up last which is the
hardest spot for Shane he dominates it's
been used yeah everyone's had their turn
that's a hard spot and he still just
dominates he stole the whole show from
that position this year and nice guy to
again always been great one of those
guys
one of the nicest guys I think a lot of
people get it twisted like it's like
just like with anything including you if
you have an outlet for your anything
then it's the opposite more right
exactly it's like people say a lot like
hey you work with Rogen a lot like those
fans must be like you know like muscley
angry dudes right it's like actually
it's the opposite it's [ __ ] muscley
guys that are interested in growing you
know beating those biases right and
being knowledgeable and intellectual and
they also work out so they have an
outlet for all that angsty energy I said
I said the same thing at cap city the we
got done with the shows and the managers
like dude we're all worried we thought
you're crowding me like these big burly
dudes like drink and smash yeah it's
like oh I can Razor Ramon Altima thwart
it's working yeah did the same like
there no that's the complete opposite it
was like they were the nicest they're so
polite to me like right and me what
laughs yeah yeah so fun you know this we
have I think we have uh I think anybody
from that Rogan side of comedy has some
of the coolest smartest fans but
especially these kill Tony's we've been
doing on the road I mean the heart you
feel the heart of the people I know that
sounds like
doesn't the excitement and the like I
was saying earlier that this is live for
us this is every DNA of every episode is
so different because you don't know
whose number you broadcast live on the
road as well or don't stream it live I'd
be a beast yeah yeah those would be fun
but though you just can't count on these
Wi-Fi Wi-Fi bang gloves and stuff so
then so when you guys are on Tori on
tour and how are you just wrapped we can
I already much go out every weekend like
it's like I mean I should make more
fancy posters and come up with crazy
names I'm all outdoor yeah yes like so
you you guys do the kill Tony you do
that when you find a town on Monday
night do it Thursday the cows it were
like it every Monday well I know you do
every Monday in uh in LA at the I'm
store but we're on the road you do a
life kill Tony what's the plan do you
fly in on Earth Wednesday do the kill
Tony Thursday then stand up you and
you're my Friday Saturday I'm normally
what it is is we fly in that day we do a
kill Tony that even which would be what
day though that same day so Thursday
Thursday sure or a Wednesday or Friday
or a set doesn't matter the day like we
do it different days just depends on
when we got booked what venue and what
else we have on that path you know like
this last we need kill Tony then let's
stand up yeah yeah one kill temp but
I'll tell you this is that I'm starting
to think that right now that may be
adding more kill Tony's really don't
think you want to leave the demand I
mean there's the demand is crazy every
single one we've ever done his cuz we
never go there all the comics through
the bucket anyway so there's so many
people that still want to get up and
then there's a bunch of and how long is
the show hour and a half yeah so why not
just do a bigger venue that to we're
working our way up to that I mean the
bigger ones that we do I mean it's so
this is my thing I wonder if kill Tony
works in a bigger venue ever thought
about that you ever seen it doesn't we
just did it in Montreal at a gigantic
theater packed still work in Santa oh it
works the stakes are higher the there's
a lot of those open mic errs they've
never performed on it
so they're like oh this instance the how
like kind of close quarters it is when I
dig a lot of times with kill Tony and I
love that the venue's changed I love
that sometimes it's in a gigantic
theater and sometimes
yeah totally sometimes the air
conditioners busted like in Fort Wayne
sometimes you're at a place that's you
know perfect for everything hilarity
that show I mean yeah and you got to be
prepared for all of it and you never
know what's gonna happen and that's a
part of the whole thing and these people
never know if they're gonna get picked
out of the bucket or when they're gonna
get picked out of the bucket so it's
about being ready yet staying calm I
guess on the road it sucks because in LA
if they don't get picked that guy [ __ ]
you I'll get the next one
yeah you know but if you're in Arkansas
or [ __ ] New Orleans some people
they're like [ __ ] dude what's he gonna
be back yeah once a year
some people will drive like if we like
we went we did Cleveland and Cincinnati
then Fort Wayne some people will drive
like one guy got up he got lucky he got
up in Cleveland and Cincinnati move so
he just drove and there's people that
boat was it different at bull he had one
strong set the first time and then it
wasn't good the second time yeah and
then some people went to all three and
didn't get pulled out of the bucket yeah
we had some people drive five hours four
hours in the Cleveland episode I think
we only had one guy from Cleveland
people do people drive from all around
because they listen to every episode
they want to start stand-up they think
they're funnier than the people getting
pulled out of the bucket I think is a
good thing because a lot of them one of
the things that my roads off so you can
believe different everyone else but when
I was younger I was obsessed a Night
Live and Jim Carrey why I like it Jim
cares like I can't do that man yeah but
I didn't see very much other stand-up or
I didn't see any other characters I'm
like I can't do that this definitely
ain't for me now if you see kill Tony
now you even see some people were like i
100% can do better than that
I know that yeah and there's some where
like holy [ __ ] that's Talent yeah I
think it helps cuz gives the spectrum of
Tommy all over the board where you're
not just seeing Jeremiah and Tony and
freaking crystally and bryan callen just
slaughter crowds mm-hmm and another cool
thing about kill Tony that I think goes
under the radar a lot is that there's
something for everyone there's
every type of art is happening at once
there's stand-up comedy right there's a
podcast there's a band playing music
they're sound effects there's an artist
drawing the show
there's improvisation coming from the
band character we're coming from the
band the whole thing isn't planned at
all so it's like every form of you know
how many mark and then what the thing
looks crazy about it is it wouldn't work
with any like let's say comedy central's
okay we're gonna buy kill Tony it
wouldn't work well that's exactly what
their executives think Brendon that's
why you would never work on a network
why you will always be on YouTube
forever but that's not a bad thing
everyone has this dream of TV TV TV but
you guys are so multi-dimensional no TV
network I'm sure they want to build it
and eventually guys will get bought out
because of this but right now there's no
economy century ago we're gonna overtake
we're gonna buy it from you I'm gonna do
all the same stuff right there's no way
yeah without all your on your network
for an hour and a half and then they can
watch it here then you upload the
podcast and you do this and then you pay
these people and you do this no there's
no way I told them I mail it to I die
pitch to them come in come into the
Comedy Store with five cameras every
Monday put them on rollers make it look
pretty and edit down the hour and a half
to your favorite 22 minutes there's a
gigantic built-in following blah blah
blah blah I told them all this you tried
doing this yeah tried it in fact I
pitched it to them I think two or three
times to be honest with you it's crazy
it's a tough business up that's not you
know here's how it would work well
you're I think you're going about it
wrong we can spit ball right now I love
it because I think what Comedy Central
lacks is they don't have a digital
presence there's no do if you if you
don't have a digital presence you're
getting lost in the [ __ ] dust and you
look at any other major network they all
have it
ESPN's Plus now they have digital you
know there's Facebook Instagram any
major corporations trying to go that way
Netflix all that stuff has to be
on-demand so if I'm countering sanchong
run all right we have no digital
presence at all we got to figure this
out
Showtime said same thing we offer you
this out what they do that came after me
I've made my name in the digital space
so with Comedy Central they're like we
need a presence it also has to be in
comedy who has a big following you to
you guys what's a quality show you guys
man we have no podcast network you guys
so you'd take this umbrella deal too for
them to take it in I so any young
listener who's worried economy central
and you want to [ __ ] put your foot in
the door with the boss you should be
pitching to kill Tony's Comedy Central
going no no [ __ ] your TV tosh point-o
that's your guys baby that's only you
last for how much longer you if you guys
don't get hip we're gonna be [ __ ]
dinosaurs yeah and kill Tony's the way
we can get hit there's no doubt in my
mind that it's gonna end up somewhere
where it should be yeah now that's your
plan when it happens yes exactly but
yours you're a hundred percent right and
that's exactly how your agents are who
you know you want to vape here they're
great they're at WME yeah power power
power team no they're unbelievable yeah
yeah they're great they just they just
took over I just you know made a little
you just which I realized oh you just
ran to switch room yet from from the old
boys for my old boys yeah yeah yeah
that's the a yeah yeah I guess so you're
gonna edit this part out are you gonna
make it louder try to bury my career
again chin chin is that gonna be the
part they put on who will be co-host up
do those 118 agents last year just a
supercut huh Brennan go kill Tony will
never be friend and believes killed
Tony's going no way yeah you know we're
just trying to figure it out but you
know what's really important is we have
to not change you need to not change to
make it PC or I would never I would not
do
I would never do that even my soul would
disintegrate into nothing no it'sit's
it's edgy for sure yeah every week you
never know what's gonna happen
we can go racial we can go something
some tragedy that happened that week
what the band dress up as hurricanes
when we like you know sad disaster
whatever you know you got to make
lighter sure yeah we came out with we
had like like blue tarp on us and like
cows stuck to the office piece of
garbage
Joel Jimenez Joel Berg and he's like he
did like art department on Nathan for
you on Comedy Central so he's really
good at that and anything that takes
like crafty Ness he'll do but then we'll
collaborate on like what did to pick out
like cosmos and the characters that they
do oftentimes acknowledge you know a lot
of what's happening in the world like
Jeremiah has this one character that is
a star on the show called feminist
Stacey she represents you know all women
and you know just sort of like those
types of feminists that you see on
social media and stuff that just are
intolerable and you hate everything I
ran one in Austin because on it has a
house there for like the they're they're
guests they bought a house and I'm
saying at this house and there's a we
there's a porch light on and she comes
out and in the yard there's like signs
like purple green orange black white
everyone's approved in this house and
then it's like vote YES on amendment
seven all that [ __ ]
she's so earthy she's like a liberal and
she comes out and she's all hey are you
staying out like yeah I'm staying here
and I go but I don't own it she's no man
I know who owns it she was I just bought
a new out and he's like to keep my owl
up like Jesus Christ know I've got a new
owl in the crib and just was like
[ __ ] on us yeah I thought everybody
was accepted here but not lights
Oh Oh do you have an issue with women
Brendan Schaub I'm
my feminist Stacey here are you talking
disparagingly about women and earthy
folk what else do you want to talk about
Brendan oh do I want to get below the
belt now I don't think so what's a boys
club hey how come there isn't a female
that's in the running for bats go have a
year
Brendan huh oh you got your you got your
Theo von your deadly eyes you don't get
Tony but you get your wrap up [ __ ] on
there what about a full-grown
independent smart one man this is
feminist Stacy
bro who's upset about everything
everything I'm triggered by everything
on this show no estrogen on the show
right now except in this couch right
here testosterone is off the charts
yeah are you talking about your cell you
have a lot of beard hair coming in Stacy
yeah sorry I'm a full grown woman and I
let my body free you should see my pits
I'm completely unshaven and guess what
yes my pubes are a mess Brendan because
guess what as a woman I can keep them if
I want it is my body my choice yes I
have nipple hair too but you will not
see them unless I want to because I
could free the nipple right now that is
my choice as a woman if I want to
protest it that's me the only thing
that's that's this nice and woman in
here is the way that Brendan is sitting
right it's nice to see your name'll tail
popping at the bottom of those jeans
it's beautiful let it free Brendan let
everything go below the belt that needs
to be out there Campbell tail
yes look at like the fighter in the skin
down there oh I'm sweating bro you're
keeping him up he needs his rest
any idea don't buy a [ __ ] owl yeah
who does that who who does that huh man
Stacy you are out of control today yeah
sorry I just wanted to drop by fighter
in the kid you're lucky Brian's not here
to be all over you Stacy
Oh egg me too oh I'm sure there would be
a me too movement and I would report his
ass immediately yeah he'd put it in your
low-budget movie okay you know what this
is enough I don't know how much more I
can take a bit feminist Stacy out you
know what I find fascinating is that
they get the Comedy Store there's
there's only one
Jeremih but there's like like how it
it's gonna be so cool and like I don't
know five years if not sooner when
Jeremiah's just way more famous than
everyone we know no but there's guys
like Jeremiah not a germ eyes level he's
the next one yeah but there's other
talented guys out that I see on the road
and I see at the Comedy Store who are
just no one knows who they are you go
see him [ __ ] any night of the week
right now and they're just these
monsters and that's the same thing you
see in fighting or anything where you're
like it's it's a matter of time yeah
like this guy has it I mean I was
talking like to reminds not in the room
with passed away yeah no you remember
the time when Jeremiah hey guys I just
stepped out I just got back well Stacey
[ __ ] the whole show okay
no you're spot-on dude I was touring the
country with Tiffany Haddish never heard
of her and red band six years ago we
were triple co-headlining shows together
it was like you know back when they're
the back when it was a tight little
death squad back when everybody was just
starting podcasts and it was just all
the rage and smoke show back then I did
moneymaker huh you know I'm saying like
some girls who they're alright and then
they get money like goddamn girl she had
a child carried herself like a star all
the time she was always fine
she was always able to tap into it she
realized when a moment to shine was she
it was there was the same feeling of
impending success you know it's just
about it you feel from Jeremiah was with
her and it's the same exact thing with
him like there's just some people in
which you're like how hasn't it happened
yet how hasn't like Tiffany was that
person and then all the way so it's
probably better to have that type of
thing than too slowly and I think it's
better to have it over the year then
like it's a slow boil and when you're
just starting and then goes like oh sure
yeah a lot of stuff to do but now all
eyes are those people flame out so when
they get something that people think
they weren't ready for but when people
get something in this business that they
were way too ready for will be Aaron
Rodgers yeah you want being around you
don't be Johnny Manziel yeah you wanna
be gets thrown in the starting position
like holy [ __ ] man give me a little more
time let me learn from some of the
legends like Brett Favre let me get my
wings underneath me then I'm ready to go
yeah I'm being robbed it's like a Space
Shuttle you need our initial boosters to
get out of the atmosphere and then for
another and you know it's like it takes
multiple engines and but you have to get
all the way up and all the way out for
it to happen things you let go of on the
way you know boosters and this and that
you have to be built strong and tough
too crazy you read ban and Tiffany
Haddish just the three of us each to one
45 minutes flipping the order around
craziness it was it was so much fun we
did we went everywhere together we drove
across Texas how did that I mean I gotta
be honest I don't like you red band
Tiffany Haddish I don't I don't see how
that connection I crush fast it happened
it happened by you know we were just
doing a lot of podcasts together and you
know she was on Kel Toni multiple times
and she's just always one of our
favorite people and you know we wanted
to we wanted to have a another funny
person with us read ban and I did and
Tiffany was the perfect fit she's fun to
hang out with she's fun on the road
she's fun in the green room
on airplanes dope she's just the coolest
check she's fun to drink with no he's
fun to you know eat breakfast with you
know it's one of those things to where
she's just a cool person all the time
you're talking about like people who you
know you're like how they not blown up
yet that was Tiffany for four years like
I always tell people like whenever
they're like man I can't get up like at
the Comedy Store or this spot or
whatever am like don't get discouraged
like Tiffany is a perfect example that
she couldn't get on yeah the potluck at
the Comedy Store she could like I
remember the host would have her come up
and queef in the microphone and that was
her saves time right yeah this lady can
queef another micro come up do it and
then look at it yeah yeah holy [ __ ] man
now you can't even get her to respond to
your text messages and by your I mean my
[Laughter]
yeah sakes yeah I remember for the
five-year anniversary of kill Tony I
remember texting her like hey you know
we have our five-year anniversary coming
up you know at about 9:40 is when the
current regular Malcolm's gonna be on
stage you don't need to do anything you
could come through the fire exit of the
you could just pull your s you have your
driver drop you off you can walk right
up come out on stage while he's on grab
a microphone and say you can accomplish
your dreams you know anything you want
to say just quick and easy and you can
walk right out right it's literally like
what you'll do to get an appearance from
someone I basically gave her that and
I'm like oh man I can't believe she
didn't respond to my then I looked on
the news or whatever that night she was
hosting the MTV Video Awards like it's
like yeah God and I'm like a little bit
bit I'm like man - II didn't pod on Cal
town I don't think it's uh in some
people I got she's changed nope she got
a [ __ ] new number she was busy oh she
has a new Disney number
she swamped and there's a schedule now
and be like you
you've changed like no I know literally
lucking swamp man like I'm I'm my head's
fully into them TV music awards that
have to hope she she was uh she's great
like she's still super down-to-earth an
awesome I was out in New York whenever
she hosted SNL and I got to see that
episode and yeah she was so sweet like
like everybody was obviously wanting her
attention so much but she made time to
see me and other friends from back at
the store you know what I mean yeah like
yeah it's great it's really cool
yeah like when I see like that stuff
like you red band TIFF and you guys
always on the road like I see and we're
kind of doing or we're playing without
talked a little bit at the time store
with you where you know that the the
blue collar tour where Jeff Foxworthy
they brought all those guys with them
they just did theaters and like one
night only like that I feel like we need
to do something like that we have one in
October where it's Theo Ari Brian and
big J oh wow this is the fourth that's
gonna be incredible it's already almost
sold out I think there's like 200
tickets left in Psych it's sixteen
hundred Cedars yeah how could ya that's
that's an undeniable show it's great
show but here's the thing though you
know it off CR in big J or New York
comics but I think our group in LA if we
do that one one time a month and we do a
theater tour yeah and you label theater
tour but you booked it out in the year
before you know for the year you say you
know in December in Chicago jr. here but
they know and you just read all out you
have the year to buy the ticket yeah the
venue and it's like whatever the four
horsemen or the five of us and we should
do twenty minutes
but you get that way the same way Jeff
Foxworthy did you get that his audience
then you get the kill Tony audience yeah
and you get the feel Vaughn audience the
Bryan Callen audience maybe and then you
get but it did understand so you could
get together like a group of four where
we all commit to it yeah our crazy
schedules that would be fun yeah no I'd
love that I'd love to cross audiences
Vinnie Theo and get to see it you know
have some fans that have mullets and
wifebeaters in their eighties Oh
of you you remind me of when a
hippopotamus put sunglasses on why the
hippopotamus got wd-40 I don't know
we'll see we'll see we'll sleep good God
you put a belt around that man I know
you're the Dana white of your the Dana
what I'm given interim belts out now
he's slacking bro
you get an interim belt should we do
some current events sir I love this I
feel like all these are always made up I
don't know how chin finds these things
let's hope they're good well since
you're big WWWE guy mm-hmm that guy Glen
Jacobs one yes mayor of Fort Knox
Tennessee yeah all right that's Kane
yeah hey I'm big came he was huge yeah
Undertaker's little brother by the way
this guy still wrestles he's never
gotten injured he has done like every
Royal Rumble every WrestleMania for
life's 20 years oh yeah I mean could
yeah I'm sure there's a little something
going on there he's the biggest face in
the world yeah that [ __ ] dude looks
like a comic book hero
that's a gourd yeah good god you know
that's the Undertaker's a little brother
hey who's the homeboy who died
do you have that chin pride none rock
poster go to rock suits Bryan Lawler
Jerry the king's son he commits suicide
yeah uh he uh he got a DUI and then I
think he got another DUI or something
like that he was just really depressed
and he hung himself in a in a hospital I
think it's CT again they blame it on
that I'm like or the bees sometimes like
we thought we I think we throw up CT too
much these days yeah like I think it's
combination things where he was huge in
the limelight and then whatever reason
yorkers night-gaunts way and you get
depressed any lights not the same and
then it's just like they're like [ __ ] it
man you know right I don't think it's
always brain trauma
yeah oh we can blame wrestling for us
you know all the time or football or
whatever it is you know and it's tough
to be the son of a of a king we've
learned that on on Game of Thrones and
things like that and to be Sheree the
King Lawler son is a tough footsteps to
follow in you know you could see from
the
range of pictures there that he's always
trying to find himself and is here yeah
exactly you know trying to figure out
how he could stand out he was one of
those guys that did he ever get big not
really know he never really took off it
just wasn't a thing that happened isn't
Jerry Lawler like friends with Andy
Kaufman yeah we're a slapped in the cop
in on yeah epic stuff epic I mean oh you
know I think about doing two is let's
say it off here exactly but I might be
switching Studios and their build
certain stuff and I think we should do
wrestling companions around WWE hello I
don't know if you know this or not but I
I do a podcast we just had episode 100
of a podcast called the store horsemen
and Joe Rogan was on episode 100 this
was last week and it's based off of
wrestling completely all about pro
wrestling my childhoods all the way to
now and and if you I don't know if
you're free or not but at the end of
this month we're doing our first ever
live companion in the belly room we're
gonna watch SummerSlam all together with
microphones oh damn SummerSlam dude it's
gonna be awesome in the belly room
August uh something in one of the last
Sunday's and awesomo I'm sure other
people are doing but I think they could
be cool no set up you come ww back yeah
I'm in cool all the way I mean there's
nothing more able to be joked about than
WWE so I went to like a wrestlemania
viewing party with with tony and some of
our other buddies and it was one of the
most fun nights because there's so many
jokes that are being thrown around just
about everything that's going on
you put a room of comedians in front of
a wrestling screen it's game set match
and we were soaking it in for ourselves
for years until the point to where like
what are we doing plus we were catching
up talking about wrestling for an hour
every week yeah the same group of people
were like why don't we just do this with
microphones in front of our faces yeah
and it's it's Charlie you do that and
you do your yeah golden pony at the Pony
hour yep well I'm about to restart the
pony our took a little hiatus for a year
because I've just been touring so much
and everything's just been chaos lately
but but yeah I'm gonna start that back
up in about a week or two but yeah we do
kill Tony and the store horsemen and the
pony our motion writing jobs and one of
the you know busiest touring comedians
now they're in one city to the next I
got just got Mary got a four month old
puppy oh you would kind of Doug a half
Australian Shepherd half beagle I'm
testing out what sofa what a half
Australian half American would be like
you know and I got a new Corvette
on the way here
it's pretty dope yeah I'd say yeah we
got from zero to fifty in like two
seconds two seconds bro on Instagram oh
no I don't like bragging about my spread
on my Instagram just on podcast that
little key iconic dog
Mallory Hinchcliffe you sure there's not
some Rottweiler than that thing there
might be they said they said beagle mix
how did you get it from a pound if if by
Beverly Hills super professional pound
yes it's a fancy pound did you save the
dog yeah we saved it from it's from it's
more comforting something that you saved
him look at that shiny coat okay that's
cutest [ __ ] I like his nose yeah she's a
little baby girl I wouldn't forget Jim
all right these comments on says she has
your face I'm sure you've seen this
already Russian names action movie star
Steven Seagal as human terian
humanitarian envoy to the US now Steven
Seagal is gonna save the world I like
what is happening where it's like Dennis
Rodman Steven Seagal like what is this
like anyone who's qualified or current
yeah Robin Steans ago yeah you're the
last thing there's like we like people
from 90s and not is it well that's
Russia in China yeah yeah if Mel Gibson
goes over to [ __ ] China they're like
yeah
yeah it's weird all these people that
are world diplomats an hour like all off
of Celebrity Deathmatch like what's in
what's next our new ambassador to
England is Tonya Harding dude it's
[ __ ] strange man and Steven Seagal I
mean wasn't in a sex ring in New Orleans
he had some [ __ ] man
no I type in Steven Seagal sex ring and
the weird thing is maybe some [ __ ] I
keep working with Russia meanwhile yeah
it's like a swollen man yeah is he Asian
Steven Seagal I think is kind of like
the older he gets the more Asian he more
like is like is he getting better at
martial artists using like a huge sex
ring bro yeah now that's a sexual
assault Oh heads up chin stare about
Google best I know he's bad candidates
will it be Jenny McCarthy alleged sexual
harassment my Steven Seagal all right
welcome to club Wow yeah I don't see how
there is keeping sex slaves sues all
sued that's USA Today - bro you're
screwed man that's today.com sex slaves
human sex life you mean being a big dick
bandit I mean these hoes just want to
hang around the crib hanging around the
underseas crib bro hard to kill rope
yeah dude that's not hard to kill Fame
he does all his own stunts
young personal attendants women to serve
strangers sometimes violent sexual
desires but you just keep her at their
house I guess it's too young female
Russian of course attendants who were on
call for sex 24/7 I want to know what he
was into like what uh what sexual things
was he into like I could just picture
him wanting to get like his ass eaten
that's pretty much it
he thinks yeah I see why like I see him
the type do once you're kicked in the
nuts and like have nunchucks -
yeah shove it in movies oh-oh-oh-oh sex
with a girl you gave me fire down below
I stick it in your exit wound and look
at all these bad action movie yeah like
these are [ __ ] terrible
pistol-whipped I was once at a UFC fight
I was in front row Toronto it was when
GSP fight Jake sealed shields and I was
in the second round there's a row in
front of me and Clay Guida was sitting
in front of me
you know Clay's small I can still see
the cage I [ __ ] you in Hut some dude
came out in a suit whispered and clays
ear clay left and input Steven Seagal
and he's just you know he's a big dude
and it's me and like Mitrione Ryan Bader
a bunch of like tough dudes Andrei
Arlovski officers just behind seems to
go like dude I can't see and so and he
kept standing up and someone goes
someone say something and then all the
fighters I hit Steven Seagal so I went
down in front [ __ ]
and he turned around while I just
everyone we were all scared comes around
and slaps watched did he see it worked
yeah that's it Harold that night
sometimes you just gotta sometimes you
just gotta say something I had a weird
one happen yesterday I woke up on a
flight like four hours into a flight and
I'm focusing my eyes and I looked down
and the guy to my life now my right is
the window right I'm against the window
front row so I looked down to my left
cuz I'm you know trying to wake up focus
my eyes and this guy's texting and I
just so happened to look down at what
he's texting penny says and he says I'm
sitting in the middle seat between two
weirdos I'm just waking up what makes
meal weirdos I look over across him
because I'm like maybe there's a weirdo
on the other side of them and I look and
it's this cool cowboy like American like
legend guy with a mustache like you look
like dude yeah guy at the bar on bit Big
Lebowski
yeah or whatever like I'm like that guy
seems cool why am i weird weird so now I
keep looking like I can't like stop
looking at what he's texting and what
he's got going like oh my god and it
turns out he's got a conversation with
three or four different people like the
guy next to me is the window shut what a
weirdo Jesus one person's like do you
know where you're at now he's like I
think I'm over the Grand Canyon but I
wouldn't know cuz the weirdo next to me
has the window shut right so one point
I'm like you know what follow this guy
right so I reach for the window shutter
and I start to lift it up that's slowly
and as I lift it up and get it about
half way I just put my whole face in
front of the window and I'm looking back
and forth and out the window for a few
seconds then I start to lean back and I
just shot it like I do love reading
people's texts and I wanted to save my
point is I wanted to say something you
know you're the [ __ ] right I knew
that's all
like oh yeah well you're a [ __ ]
weirdo you're a weirdo why you reading
my texts my [ __ ] wallet broken weird
yeah I read people's tax all of it now
by the way I know everything about the
guy cuz I was watching his phone the
last hour of the flight I know what
emails he gets I know he's talking to
his side-chick on snapchat his passcode
yeah yeah yeah that's how they cut that
one couple with the [ __ ] sex slave
girl a couple was on the plane and they
were they were texting or dude was
texting and some Snoopy old lady behind
was reading the text and there was about
a some girl like trapped in their
basement she [ __ ] bought it and they
saved the girl Wow he pays off to be a
snitch
yeah and Snoopy that's right well what
else get gin let's take a look let's
take a look let's take a look oh well
this is not a great one but the
Venezuelan president if there was an
attempted attack on him
with the drone barely could events are
tough this week as we go Wow waylynn
president still alive that's the news
today so does it show this drone trying
to kill him you can see the commotion
here so attempted assassination with how
they tried doing it like dropping a bomb
on them yeah those bombs connected to
the drone they try to detonate it see
this they try detonated yeah they don't
like what the that guy has no emotion
don't give a [ __ ] though people start
freaking out right around you'll see
they all run yeah you see they're off
getting all sweet and uniformed
organized in line once they notice
what's going on
now they're all booking it whoa jeez let
me went to commercial but uh I guess it
was just a drone with a bunch of bombs
on yeah so there's two drones one got
one accidentally crashed into a building
this one this one was thwarted by like
some electronic signals that this guy's
team had also be preparing yeah oh sit
yeah you gotta figure that you got to
know what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] oh yeah
it's amazing destroy a drone with
electronic signals we can't even keep
our Wi-Fi solid at the comedy storage
pretty cool story model and worse man
really I love t-mobile you [ __ ] with
t-mobile yeah really
hotmail you got you have t-mobile - yeah
oh wow I love t-mobile man I've been
with the other guys they're all aiming
you know I fly a lot which t-mobile is
good for get the free yeah I fly
internet for an hour at least if you log
in if you clean your cookies and log in
again it works again yeah talking about
it on podcast but there's a little some
gift on you can't say uncle Tony never
did anything for you
head on the plane and that's why I'm
eternal weird I'm gonna be sitting next
to you for hours alright this should be
a little better so this is going viral
right now some guy who is just like I
guess it says harassing a bison he was
arrested earlier for for a traffic
violation and he was also kind of drunk
so he got bond from that arrest and they
went back on the road saw a bison and
started messing around with this bison
how do you three times already two over
started [ __ ] on the Bison yeah it
shows a man taunting a Bison condom do
was really really bad ideas check this
one out traffic was stopped in
Yellowstone National Park it's a big
[ __ ] animal and yeah the road but one
man decided to get out and taught the
animal watch this he were
flexes its muscle what he apparently did
not know is that this is bison mating
season oh no what is he thinking he's
just out of his mind
it's Dominus the encounter did and
nobody got hurt but Parkinson's drunk
you see this dad I'm gonna take on a
bicep dude that thing's [ __ ] you
three times faster than most people okay
Vedant wow what a great move go get out
and harass a bison anyone who does not
wait what are you making fun of a bison
hey nice horn and the traffic stop with
the [ __ ] you I like the Flex like he
tried to show what I wanted is that
bison is sperm through the [ __ ] leg
yeah that would be news gen alright
here's the door what have you guys seen
this yet a raccoon and a crow I saw this
on nature's metal insert I don't know
this sounds like a racist cartoon you
guys jumped the shark y'all seen one
about the raccoon and the crow yeah it's
like maybe it's unique what is going on
chin takes off a massive steel
[Laughter]
I forgot hit record oh my and well I
guess we'll slate please check this out
I've never seen this before this is
exciting watch what happening I think
that excited is that guy [ __ ] with
the Bison I can already tell you right
now the crow is going to swoop in on the
hawk [ __ ] and oh the raccoon attacked it
and starts eating it oh wow I couldn't I
didn't think raccoons could you know
like Raj Feinberg 2,300 views and chin
is convinced you're that leader of
Awesome as apparently chin trying to
sabotage your episode no he's like you
know the news it's getting hot in Texas
you want to talk about the weather in
Texas Brennan also traffic in LA is
really rough today am i right all right
how about this one where LeBron James
and Donald Trump are going yet yeah but
Trump said a really messed up thing is
LeBron LeBron James was just interviewed
by the dumbest man on television Don
Lemon
he made LeBron look smart which isn't
easy to do I like my oh I'm gonna I'm
gonna play devil's advocate here for a
second because I will say this is that
Don Lemon might be one of the fakest
most agenda pushing likes a DP always
pretends like he's just so emotionally
moved by whatever just happened that day
like the phony crap that that guy does
so on that side of things I will say
that is that I agree with the President
on this that uh you know Don Lemon is
one of the I mean I wouldn't say the
dumbest man on television but he's just
a phony and this is a world where people
you know think that that's a real news
channel and they expect that to be you
know fair and balanced reporting
meanwhile it's a pain yeah but the
problem lemon blood effort right Don
lineman playing the game Bob and so
you're gonna get some of this [ __ ] but
saying he made LeBron look smart which
isn't easy to do I like Mike even Mike
was like I'll [ __ ] with Trump I like
LeBron here so to say LeBrons
whatever d'amour that's what he's based
trying to do you talk about a guy who
just announced he opened a school that's
gonna help so many at-risk kids
well you're not talking about a guy with
a photogenic memory
yeah I'll know he's not stupid and he's
the best basketball player on the planet
yeah and you just don't like him because
he said something about you also for you
the president I don't want you using
words like dumbest man on television and
all this [ __ ] like it's not right it's
so amateur man yeah I mean if you watch
a Don Lemon segment I could understand
why Trump would say this but not to the
side it's really ridiculous how childish
this tweet is out of almost all the
Trump tweets I would put this one
perhaps at the very top of dumbest
things in my opinion silly [ __ ] and
exactly I wouldn't answer and I think
that's part of his method granted you
know Trump likes to be funny and
entertaining and he didn't have to throw
that I like Mike in there like come on
he's being silly
yeah and but to say he made LeBron look
smart which isn't easy to do
it's like c'mon mr. Prez I mean it's
just embarrassing like when you travel
international you're a little
embarrassed cuz it all you know it does
bring up trouble right I'm like no no I
didn't vote for him chill yeah and I
mean LeBron has done so much great stuff
it's incredible I have no idea how that
I promise school is gonna stay open
seems like they're given the house away
but I wish him the best of luck it seems
like a really nice thing free tuition
free scholarships free food free
transportation like who's really paying
for this come on here so there's another
weird thing about this when uh when
Michael Jordan supported LeBron he said
that a list I support LeBron James he's
doing an amazing job for his community
so some people were pointing out the
fact he said his community like Michael
Jordan doesn't like to put himself in
the same position as these other people
no you're overlooking it you know I
heard heard it from other like activist
block activists they're idiots
no they're just they're just picking
apart what he said in his hometown of
Ohio you know instead of saying my
community
our sanity our community is you don't
live in Cleveland
yeah but wise I'll have to be an
african-american just not
african-americans allowed in that school
does Jordan have a reputation about that
though what are we talking about yeah
that's what he wants prisons yeah he's
just a business he's a businessman so
when he says he's doing great job for
his community he's clean know how the
schools in Cleveland I'm people are
trying to pick and you know it doesn't
work here yeah that's a that's a battle
they did these are all people that just
want to see them play one on one and
they can't deal with the fact that
they'll never get to see they pick on it
right it's like they must have arrived
already
it's like Jordan schools bigger well he
doesn't have any schools what else you
got Jim all right Danny outer HAP's a
crow versus raccoon round two oh I think
that's it all the animal ones for now I
think that might be gonna answer all
right all right next one Demi Lovato she
might she finally made or she broke her
silence after her overdose so she made a
post about it go away don't worry about
it
Oh see ya always got y'all right open it
all right what is that oh it's the vodka
oh great oh oh look at the open access
that happens on this show does knock
knock knock
a little knocking knock knock the old
roaster Theo
writer producer maybe I'll film Atomics
gonna drink there is the champs how are
ya who's this scary dude are we still
recording not only are you the champ you
decide when this thing goes off the air
yeah hi nice to meet you how do you wear
that way your pants are squeezing the
rest your body
I love it when you guys roast each other
and just go crack each other just crack
each other chuckle I apologize man I'm
sorry he does not represent us man you
guys huh yeah we got figured out
good to see you though brother nice to
meet you in person man later bye guys
bye guys he's got another one after this
deal huh you had another one after this
yeah that'd be interesting
look what you've created look what you
did just got it storms in look what you
did
Wow well dudes I mean unbelievable
unbelievable sin with a goddamn bird's
nest I can't trust
it's like carrot top if he wore a prop
on his head he's a kid I've been
following a lot of bad decisions and was
from the south
yeah I figured I knock on the door Jocko
I did want to meet so that was cool
other than that guys other than that
very disrespectful very good that Jocko
thing does pretty sweet around this
Jocko chuck was a former Navy SEAL he's
like a black dawn jiu jitsu why went on
Theo's I have no idea but he's uh like a
straight badass wakes up like 4:00 in
the morning time you think he goes to
bed always wants to talk about like
badasses that wake up at 4:00 in the
morning it's like oh I wakes up before
them it's like you have to go to bed at
7 p.m.
like an old grandma at 4 p.m. yeah
that's a good point
come on woody go to bed at midnight
though people pretend like this guy's
sleep and upside down in a you know what
I mean like come on what's he doing 1:00
a.m. to 4:00 a.m. get out of here that's
I wonder he's so quiet and just made of
muscle that's like the Rockies I hitch
crazy man is scheduling easy yeah around
private jets yeah he's on a lot of soap
I'm gonna say an IV of vitamin b12 just
flowing through his veins you know all
the steroids and every kind of any how's
this work yeah we're just going bad on
the run I feel small
sometimes I just gotta do it sometimes
you got it what else you got chin what
else do you got chin with me Lovato's
survived her suicide attempt overdose
Mike I now need time to heal and do a
bunch of drug to focus on
a little recover thank you I'll show me
but I've forgotten I look forward to day
where I can say I came on the other side
ah boy so much to work with here
can we give that racoon crow video I got
I'm taking the crow this time I got 500
other girls what what really went wrong
with the crow versus the raccoon
let's do step by step of X is an hour
long of us breaking down the crow verse
raccoon what else it's like when did it
become like all right to just be like
yeah I've been a drug abuser thanks for
the beat yeah my bad I'll see you on the
other side
right right nowadays you just can admit
and apologise anything and you're a hero
but I that's actually a good point what
happened to the good old days like being
like sorry this is rock and roll yeah
lumps where's the Game of Thrones shame
that you have to wash a naked through
everybody
yeah and but everyone goes she's so
powerful and strong I don't know what
she does she's a pop star
yeah there's Friday or something right
yeah what's her big song Demi Lovato
she's huge you know who can sing are the
ladies that we forgot about the ladies
the greatness
Adele Alanis Morissette go listen to her
unplugged I'll remember unplugged yeah
old-school stands up dude Adele [ __ ]
uh with the girl passed away Amy
Winehouse killer she was a killer people
don't realize killer and killed these
chicks can't stick up that's that's a
drug addicted superstar Amy Winehouse go
watch that documentary you seen that Amy
the time you seen that yet oh good have
you seen it you bride right I'm pretty
sure I did yeah you kind of have yeah
you have satisfy her dad's suck yeah
what a creep I know it's like cameras
around she's like I don't feel good dad
please don't have this the whole time it
was him she sucked
mm-hmm that's a great doc unbelievable
is it on I think it's on Netflix now I
mean yeah he adjusts it not yeah and I
think Netflix just bought it and from
the very big
to that part where it's just a couple
little girls singing happy birthday and
she comes in yeah like [ __ ] crazy like
tenor
was so bad for a man yeah I mean just a
natural talent and that's the craziest
part cuz that little girl singing happy
birthday you can hear she's already Amy
wine put that trailer chin let drew my
old taste she had some freaky which one
would you like always uh well that's the
full doctor one that there's the trailer
the middle the middle ones this trailer
it's funny because you know big record
companies they make everybody seemed
like such a star that you can't really
tell who's a star and who's not a star
no and this my friends Amy Winehouse
there's a star freak of nature writer
performer wrote her own stuff she's like
an older soul to the oven she
intelligent most intelligent person I
knew she was so awfully authentic about
that [ __ ] boyfriend oh my god everybody
needs to watch this documentary that's
like Amy the only one better than this
the route even would be the Kurt Cobain
one is a good one music but even Kurt I
feel like was more of a style I mean I
love Nirvana you know easy right he's
but I'm talking about pipes man and a
real artist that wrote her own stuff and
velcro beta yeah
I know but it's more of a style of music
right that was like grunge music this is
a musician with a voice I heard that
just wanted to be too low oh that
[ __ ] prick right there guys he's
still alive
so many like d-bags like that out there
right yeah
and they all kill there they all had a
part they all played a part out or die
just how sad is it when she goes out the
house opposed to seeing her last show
and she just [ __ ] spoil alert she
[ __ ] up yeah she's just out of it she's
wasted I'm gonna be but they told her
she shouldn't be on the road yeah her
mom or manager and her dad won her on
the road to make money yeah and then and
even like her
everyone's like dude she should not be
around that life she needs a like a year
off they were getting 10% of Vienna and
she done hundreds of thousands of people
towards the end she was drawing in you
know she was the star I'm not okay
she could have filled any stadium
just go to things and those pipes my god
those pipes nobody has a voice like that
I agree that'll make you sad look at all
that you said I saw it in theaters it
makes you sad but it also makes you
realize you know how hard it is to do
what these people do and when they are
really when they really have a natural
talent and it and it's just them and it
falls on their shoulders and people are
waiting for their next album and they
have to follow that last album that they
made and all that pressures on them and
all these little comedy though like once
you do an hour you got a restart write a
whole new [ __ ] yeah especially if you're
like a better Seinfeld or Kevin Hart
those guys were like dude you're
supposed to be best of the best
yeah next hour better be a [ __ ]
heater and you have to do it all you
can't just do the same type of beats and
timing you also got to relate to people
because you're flying around on private
jets and you live in a life most people
can't relate to so you have to help with
[ __ ] like people can relate to
yep an asset it only gets harder you get
better but it gets harder yeah uh-oh
that's the news story this is a
Philippines president destroying eight
million dollars rate like five point
five million dollars worth of why
because they these are all imported to
the Philippines illegally what's his
name
due to our tank dude yeah he wants to
kill people yeah he's a terrible person
scary person terrible person oh wow
since they're all legal imported well go
ahead and crush that Muslim that's not
yeah dining though that dining BMW it's
an older one all right but there's not
Philippines it's kind of new he's
crushing cars with a bulldozer oh that
Lamborghini hurts my soul and there's a
Porsche Porsche on the rides pretty [ __ ]
for sure yeah dude but can you imagine
being the guy driving that house that's
a good point
oh that's it that's pretty crazy Wow
last time I saw something crushed that
hard it was me on stage last night hello
they'll got a little bit of any you know
next time I'm coming on but next time
you text me let's make it a party so my
jeremiah
thrown me under the bus like a
Lamborghini under a bulldozer in the
Philippine special any any plans
you shot the one shot which yeah yeah I
did that myself a few years ago and and
now I'm just waiting in line I mean
Netflix is queue I've been told I'm in
Netflix is cute think about that okay
very for a special like specials now
ready no I'm ready I'm waiting for them
to get rid of their favors and they're
they're pretty boys that they think are
they're a homies no I mean depending on
how the landscape continues to evolve
you know we're waiting to see what Apple
TV's about to do and all these other big
things that are about to drop hot
competition on them and certainly would
be an understatement to say that it's
never been more busy over there it's a
little bit cluttered up all they're
giving people 15 minutes specials in
half hour specials and it's like these
aren't there's a lot comes on it's
specials any forty people are you get
lost in the shuffle right I have nothing
against Netflix I should [ __ ] do a
special Netflix all I'm saying is before
it was like before Netflix are you on HP
on Showtime if you had a swatch on there
they didn't give many like why yeah
Showtime yeah HBO sick yeah how did
Central sick the Netflix come on then
it's Chris Rock Seinfeld Dave Chappelle
like holy [ __ ] Netflix is sick I mean I
look I'm like I'm gonna heard that
person and have green let's 60 specials
yeah I was very lucky my special came
out in January of 2016 so I before the
pop oh yeah it was everywhere when
everybody had it and a ton of people saw
it and it was before Dave and it was
before Seinfeld and Chris and everybody
so I wouldn't change my time on Netflix
for anything the seed was planted at a
great great spot plus it was one of the
only real outside-the-box special
at the time it being all continuously in
one shot and you know blah blah blah but
yeah the next one I'm excited about
because I actually like what I'm talking
about the material you know that first
special is also sort of like a
retirement party for all the material
that you come up with at the beginning
by the time you shoot it like god I
can't wait to get rid of this yeah and
my two-year licensing deal with Netflix
is up so it's not even on Netflix
anymore you can you really send YouTube
yeah I own it yep launch it yeah yeah
it's out there Oh sick but then again
I'm also thinking about having that
taken down because just because I'm
excited about what I'm working on now I
did see I think it only helps you yeah a
little bit sort of a little bit sort of
I am I think I'm maybe five to ten times
funnier at hope then I was three years
ago we're sure so I just don't want the
wrong impression being out there if that
makes sense I'm proud of what I did I'm
proud of what it's gotten me and so but
I think we're in on a new level you know
I look at Connor back when he's fighting
and you know whatever I earn oh I hear
how it still was a good special yeah
yeah no I agree I mean I think everyone
flinches out their old [ __ ] no matter
what it is I think oh I know I really do
I really feel that way about that thing
and you know it just feels so old to me
yes and the new stuff I'm having so much
fun with it I'm talking about stuff and
having sets right now that you know I'd
put up against and I lot of stuff I
don't want to sound crazy because I want
to say that I should be the champ but as
far as current events that's pretty much
it but since uh Tony's here what do you
think of you wanna you and Jay check how
she responds to you know last time I was
on here this is how long it's been
before yeah you did it was before Yoanna
Rose won and I don't maybe I said on it
but I told Java I don't think your
girl's gonna win and you know the thing
about the UFC which makes it fun but
also sort of sucks is that it's all
about
Isles right it's all about Styles all of
a sudden almost everything goes out the
window I look at this
TJ Cody battle this week right and you
look at it and I thought Cody was gonna
take it really right but no I don't know
why I thought that because TJ has his
number and I think back at what because
I was at that Cody Dominick Cruz fight
and I was watching him shuffle his feet
and then wind up his hands and just look
silly and in part that way that he made
him look like a fool yeah and yeah I
watched what Dominic when Dominic fought
TJ and it was a war right and then TJ
just has Cody's number it's so much a
battle of styles that sometimes our
brains and I mean maybe not yours maybe
it's mine because you're more educated
obviously than I am but sometimes my
brain gets confused because it's like it
doesn't know exactly how styles will
match up if that make sure I think
there's styles but then also with
Johanna and it's not always about stuff
sometimes - like Rose is just a better
fight I also think I could coach Yoanna
to victory against Rose there's one good
there's one thing that she hasn't been
doing in these fights and tell me if I'm
crazy about leaving yeah there's one but
there's a thing in her repertoire yeah
smooth Brendan I see what you're doing
smart UFC guy yeah she isn't winning
very good say she stopped doing this
snap kick this of the put yeah nasty
snap front kick that was one of her
trade marks just like Holly sets up her
nasty kick with punches her knockout
kick yeah Johanna used to set up her
punches with this nasty titty kicked I
mean that just [ __ ] it is that the
actual terraform snap kick to the chest
the bargain that that woke all those
chicks right up and then made them
flinch when the punches were coming I'll
tell you honest problem I don't think
it's a front kick thing I think is
technique thing I think it's the
ownership thing what she loses she lost
her fight to Rhodes the first one and
none of it was her fault yeah it's not
my fault that I didn't cut weight right
because my my coaches who were cutting
weight didn't do it proper and then
actually won that fight okay let's run
this back they run it back she gets beat
him and worse oh not my fault I was off
again the weight wasn't right something
else was going on but I won that fight
so she's not she's not continuing to get
better you know she's she's that comic
who's bombing and he gets off staging
like it's like I thought it went well
yeah well hold on No here there's mom
you hear the crowd it's very black and
white right who lost yeah this is a
fight you lost that crowd like know how
much you can keep doing what I'm doing
that's not working you have to do
something different nope I'm gonna keep
doing that all right [ __ ] it keep doing
that you're never gonna get better
that's what you want in this I agree uh
completely she's a stylist which I'm
happy about
yeah she's dressing way better she's
just wearing the white polo like a
[ __ ] serial killer I love her
she's amazing J I just love ioannis
style but you know it's one of those
things to where she's got to get it
together she's gotta make it about the
fighting and one or last fight but I
think she look great right I didn't yeah
I didn't think so either but you got it
she's got a just she's kind of look back
at her old videos that snapped member
who shows up everything it's set up
everything they were taking her punches
you know you would see it you know say
that she throws 20 punches and they'd be
good but then once she hit them with
that front kicked right to their chest
it changed the way they thought for the
rest of the fight so all she was landing
more punches at a higher rate higher
quantity busting these girls open all of
a sudden they're bleeding elbow elbow
because she's in now and they're just
happy they're not getting that kick to
the chest again they just know they
can't handle another one or two of those
we can end on this UFC news - there's
two of them so your boy Nate Diaz is
fighting yeah it kind of threw a fit
because he was in center of tension but
whatever yeah yeah I don't blame him
either I mean you know he is such a draw
he's so entertaining to watch they're
not going to kept that but not a bigger
draw than Conor could be I agree so when
he throw a fit yeah I think it was a
tight move what he did yeah he's now
everyone's talking about it
exactly he reminded people that you know
he's an interesting fella yes
just gonna sit back and he's not gonna
be the guy take the Trello until you see
yeah yeah and he's just so entertaining
and so fun it's funny that the that the
stoner tough-guy also cares that much
right yeah so I just love the dynamic
and I'm excited to see what he does how
do you like him in that fight what do
you think stylistically about that one
uh if it was two years ago I like Nate
all day yeah cuz the long way off and
kind of the recent things he's going
through it's it's a it's a such a tough
fight to call right it's a tough fight
to call it stylishly it's a good fight
for him yeah and then Connor could be
Wolf's official hot here we drive you to
see fan are you staring at the wall
right now um listen I'm not a big fan I
hear yeah I just covered this ship for
two hours but I do want to get Tony
staging my thing with that is and again
my could be way off here but I feel like
if Connor can do his crazy Aldo trickery
that he did and if he's emotional he
could hop khabib on that chin sometime
in the first two minutes I think he'll
have the strength to do something crazy
right but if he starts to wear down that
Conner gas tank is no joke I mean we've
seen it exposed against Nate we saw it
exposed against Mayweather we've seen
that he's not he's he's a he's a he's an
exploder
yes plosive but the catch is being
explosive is that you know your recharge
ability right yeah yeah and he misses a
few of those punches this and that all
of a sudden he's a little bit more tired
such a good fight the beep shoot slow
starts those monkey punches and slamming
them from the side and Connor doesn't
like taking punches we learned that
against Nate too yeah you know he does
not like getting hit fight though yeah
it's gonna be great it's two of the best
going up against each other but with
this one I also think what you said with
Nate taken a couple years off that's
exactly what I'm thinking about this
Conor thing no it's like you know
running roasters real brother it's very
real time time to be a fight fan though
yeah it is time to be a jermiah fan and
Tony fan but can I also say in closing
that nothing I think is cooler than this
Daniel Cormier stuff
going on I'm a huge DC fan to always
have been and I don't think there's ever
been anything more WWE than a guy
winning the light heavyweight and the
heavyweight belts at the same time what
an amazing listener what an amazing
accomplishment and I just think it's so
cool that that guy is also one of the
good guys one of the good guys
and one of the great commentators I mean
to have that my favorite cone - me too
same thing I think you know Cormier
Rogan Anik all day I could watch I could
watch football paper I could watch
raccoons fight crows in with those guys
doing the college where can they find
you guys we on the road next we are in
Lexington Kentucky and doing a kill Tony
in Nashville on next Sunday we're doing
a kill Tony's in Toronto Detroit Lansing
Grand Rapids Houston Austin San Antonio
Dallas all coming up Tony Hendra cliffs
calm you could watch live streaming on
youtube you can come to the comedy store
in LA watch on a Monday we're back every
Monday no matter where we go we fly back
to do it doing it tonight live in the
main room
I'm swing by sometime chin I'll give you
the give you the Royal Treatment unlike
you when you make your videos I mean
it's on below they got add you man gonna
add both if I'm in the video this year
if I make the video you're definitely in
the but if you don't make the video then
give a [ __ ] note to the person guy if
I make the video like you know you're
giving it to somebody to not to do by
the way you said that you're gonna get
the most time to say all right dudes
well they can find you where can they
find you I've got a podcast called
Jeremiah wonders and then I've got a
debut my debut comedy album is coming
out with Pat Reagan in a couple months
yeah we're doing a music
yeah it's like a tenacious d flatly
Conchords gonna feel it's gonna be
amazing these two guys together are
geniuses they're genius separate
Jeremiah wonders is so funny plays
different characters have you done his
podcast no there you got something to it
you got to put it on your daily schedule
you know people are saying Brandon's not
doing enough hustling he's so funny
though Jeremiah wonders is crazy
switches in and Jeremiah stand up bone
and you're doing stand up on the spot
next week that's next
next Tuesday August 14th with Eric Andre
you and David Koechner so far [ __ ] yeah
and you're doing kill Tony with us next
Monday 1314 Tommy Store next Monday
Tuesday yeah hells yeah we're gonna have
so much fun I love you guys man come on
I think you somehow have all right guys
this is the fighter Jeremiah and Tony
we're out